[Music]
so in cases like that like something
like drones and something like
surveillance basically the argument is
that we sort of test this stuff out
across the world and then we sort of
bring it home and use it against
ourselves here like is that test run is
that just the government's way of we
start hearing these words and it's about
protection or something and that's
slowly we then just acquiesce to it
happening right here yes so again it's
not necessarily one of those we are
doing this explicitly abroad to try to
do it at home right but one thing that
we can see in the u.s. is that for if
you look at a spectrum of functioning
governments whether you like it or not
US government relatively well
constrained relatively well functioning
compared to what else is out there
however if you take the US and other
governments too for that matter outside
of their own geographic boundaries their
constraints are much weaker or
altogether absent so there are lots of
US intervention for example of including
things like the 2003 invasion of Iraq
which are done without approval of the
UN and yet there are no sanctions for
that we talk about other reasons why
maybe those constraints aren't there so
you go out you are facing you being
government facing weaker or absent
constraints and so you can maybe try
things and do things that would not fly
domestically but that doesn't mean that
those things don't wind up showing up
back at home so we identify how it is
that those things come back so one way
is through what we call human capital so
just the skills that people possess so
in order to be successful in a foreign
intervention whatever your role is you
have to either possess or develop
particular skills and characteristics
when you finish with that foreign
intervention the individuals who are
involved they don't suddenly forget that
knowledge right they bring it back with
them this relates to these like
a strain of dynamics of the organization
from which these individuals operate so
whether that's a public enterprise or a
private enterprise they may be well
known for a particular skill or it may
just be the attitudes that have been
cultivated as a result of these foreign
interventions that they then bring back
with them and implement into these
organizations and physical capital so
the kinds of technologies that are
developed drone to the prime example
drones are developed for use abroad been
used for a really long time but
extensively throughout the war on terror
people come back from these
interventions they see the potential use
for this technology that they have
become very accustomed to and then push
to have them used domestically right
some of that stuff I suppose at least on
the technological side can be used for
good right like Amazon using drones now
if it's going to get you your stuff
quicker and they got some of the
technological know-how through a
military thing that that could be seen
as positive now having drones flying
over a spying on us all day this could
be about a part it's not to suggest that
anything that comes out before an
intervention is necessarily bad so I
think drones is a fantastic example
because there are certainly instances
where drones have very positive uses I
am really excited for the day that I can
get food delivered by throat yeah I I
will greatly look forward to that day
yeah drones have been used for search
and rescue they are used extensively in
agriculture and those are all things
that I think most people would agree are
are great most people probably wouldn't
have too much of a problem about those
or with those but once you start getting
into those issues of surveillance
weaponize drones so you have police
departments who are equipping drones
with at this point thanks mostly less
lethal weapons you start getting into
those kinds of areas and obviously you
have people who look at that and you
know whoa whoa
right what's happening here and it also
goes to what you said earlier about sort
of the creep of all this because you
just said
is less lethal weapon' but it's almost
like well now you've just paved the road
for eventually they will have the lethal
weapons on them there are some states
that are trying to prevent that from
happening other states not so much and
drones are an interesting area of study
because they're not a new technology but
the rate at which they are being used is
substantially greater than at any point
before and so you are now seeing the
explosion of the use of this technology
yeah and so the question again comes to
those how do you get the uses that you
want out of those but avoid those things
that maybe we we don't want right and
all of these unintended consequences
that when I lived just across the hill
in West Hollywood there was a guy that
was flying a drone around the
neighborhood constantly so not only do
you hear it and you can see it obviously
but you know I had a little outdoor
patio and it was like I didn't know
there's this guy have a camera on this
thing and it's staring at me now that's
not the government that's it well for
all I know a lot of government but I'm
assuming it was somebody in there in the
local area but it's like you just start
giving away your privacy you don't even
realize what's happening and next thing
you know you've got a drone and they've
got it gone and everyone's looking at
everybody and then who can hack into all
this stuff and write a myth there was a
an individual in my neighborhood who has
a drone and he likes flying it and at
one point there had been a couple of
kids he's been breaking into cars in the
neighborhood and so he offered to fly
his drone around and sure enough within
you know just a few days of this being
offered you have people in the
neighborhood who are saying I don't want
that thing flying over my house because
they're genuinely concerned for their
privacy
right and so you get into a lot of
really interesting legal issues issues
of privacy social issues I think with
drones and so it'll be really
interesting to see how this continues to
unfold yeah let's circle back to the
surveillance stuff related to the state
though because I haven't done a
tremendous amount on it in just in the
last two years or so because I feel like
we don't really talk about it that
anymore like there was a point maybe
four years ago when all the NSA stuff
first got released and that ridiculous
testimony the James clapper gave in
front of the Senate House committee and
just an all and Rand Paul's filibuster
and all that time where it was like
there was a moment where it's so cool to
be like against the surveillance state
then I think that kind of disappeared
very quickly and it seems like we don't
talk about it anymore do you think
that's fair to say I think that there
are people who are still talking about
it I do think though that there is a
definite a band flow to when people are
talking about it and not talking about
it when the Snowden leaks came out you
had a lot of people who are talking
about it before that Thomas Drake you
had a lot of people who are talking
about it now maybe not so much and
people surveillance is a hot-button
issue even for people who tend to be
inclined toward a smaller government or
more limited government when people talk
about surveillance they will usually say
things like well but it's making us
safer or I know my dad going through the
airport for example of like well you
know as long as you know I don't have
anything to hide therefore yeah I know
that that's how that's the worst I know
oh the worst I try
have you made any headway there that's
the worst one to you uh you know maybe
but there are times to just you know CPC
sake you think our battle for parents a
little much it turned into a major
psychotherapy situation but what
happened there that we don't it seems
like just at least generally speaking we
now have just accepted that there's a
certain amount going on between phone
calls and internet and backdoors on
websites and all of this other stuff
like we've just kind of all accepted it
is that just a function of living in a
Western democracy where we've got it
pretty decent and you just you can't
fight everything all day I like that's
partly what I think it is I think a lot
of it comes back to that fear issue that
we we talked about earlier is that
people are genuinely pretty bad at
assessing risk and that's not to say
that people aren't smart just that
people tend to not do a very good job of
knowing how much of a threat that
something is and I think that people get
complacent so now the TSA example again
you go back before the year 2000 and
that seemed absolutely preposterous now
people just kind of take it as a given
and does it so much of it seem like
theater to you like whenever I go
through I travel a lot and it's like
when I go through all this so much of it
seems like sort of nonsense like they
made me throw away my my hair gel but it
was like I just knew gel like obviously
I was like you guys want to smell it
like I put it in my hair right now like
I'm not trying to build a bomb here I
only had a carry-on a little backpack
with me like you can look at everything
else I can't build like that it just
seems like well this is why we do this
and this is why we do this and they were
throwing away all this like perfectly
good stuff and fresh bottles of water
all this other stuff can't be
economically sensible either there's a
lot of discussion about the TSA a
security theater pretty much any report
that you read about the TSA indicates
that they are not effective at all and
reducing any kind of terrorist threat
and are spending a ton of money on an
annual basis
it comes back to that bureaucracy point
because then when you have the TSA who
is giving itself an exam and it fails
95% of the time it is not a time for
reflection of well is this really doing
the job that we want it to do instead is
that we need more available any more
money we need better technology and wait
let's not gloss over it so they do these
things right they do these tests where
they have people try to get stuff
through and it fails something like 95%
of economic right so people are getting
it with knives and all sorts of other
crazy things right and then the answer
is not how do we fix this the answer is
always we gotta throw more money because
it goes back to to the earlier things
right so the response is because when
you when you're confronted with failure
or less than stellar performance as a
bureaucratic agency you've got a couple
of different choices you can decide well
that didn't
work we should just ban this and try
something else or you can say this was
really not our fault it was because we
didn't have the funding that we need it
didn't have the technology that we
really needed and so there's always that
fallback of it's not failure on our part
its failure because we didn't have the
resources that we needed yeah and
there's the same political problem that
you mentioned earlier about closing down
you know a tank manufacturing place that
we don't need it's that if any
politician was like you know what we're
going to cut the TSA by 20% and try to
streamline or whatever and then there
was a terror attack well that guy is
going to be voted out of office
immediately if not impeached or some
other situation so we've really created
this mind it's like self-sustaining
monster here right how do we beat this
monster cancer is a million-dollar
question I challenge this my students
with this all the time that if they can
figure out things like a alternative
drug policy that is politically viable a
war on terror policy that is politically
viable or social security that's the
other side they can figure out a
workable solution please go and collect
your billion dollar check yeah retire
and let me know yeah it's these issues
are really complicated and one thing
that I know I find a really humbling is
that I don't have the answers and I
don't think anybody really does so when
you look at issues like surveillance
when you look at things like police
militarization when you look at things
like the war on drugs you are
confronting a potentially infinite
number of vested interest I think at a
bare minimum changing any one of those
things requires a massive shift in
public opinion which often times I think
it's a pretty heroic assumption in and
of itself but even if you do have that
major shift in public opinion then you
have to figure out well how do you
disentangle these interest that you've
spent in often times the decades
cultivating these relationships between
government and private in
three how do you go about divorcing
those and I don't have a clear answer
I've had a lot of academics in here I
don't know that I bet anyone say that
they don't have a clear answer on
something that's actually quite
refreshing oh well thank you
it's true though I get really nervous
when I hear a economist saying that they
have a very particular policy
prescription of this will fix whatever
the problem and because one thing that
economics teaches us is that every
policy has costs and had benefits and so
no policy that you implement is going to
be perfect at the end of the day the
question that we want to ask is how good
of a job do the policies that we are
implementing do of achieving the
particular goals that were interested in
working toward anyone check this stuff
does anyone go back and go let's you
know like when when they were just
trying to get this other health care the
Trump health care thing or the Paul Ryan
health care day whatever it is passed
and it was like well the CBO says it'll
cost X amount but and it's like well
they had projections when Obamacare was
coming across like does anyone look back
and go because I just don't trust any of
the numbers you know like you're giving
me a number before this thing is kicked
in like we crunched some numbers but as
you're saying is all these unintended
consequences all these other things that
happen does anyone ever go back and go
you know let's look at all the
projections that the government made all
these nonpartisan groups and all this
stuff for the last 20 years and did
anyone get any of these projections
right I feel like they probably are
never right I mean any time we're doing
forecasting you have to make certain
assumptions sometimes the assumptions
that you make wind up being pretty good
and other times they are totally off the
mark no I think it's something that you
know economists have predicted twice as
many recessions or something as there
have actually been but certainly if you
go back and you look at what people have
said with regard to policy you'll find
that some people have maybe been
accurate some people a lot of people
have have not do we learn from the
mistakes right I guess I guess
um I think that that's a taller order
and again I think it comes back to the
very simple what incentives do you face
even though people might be aware that a
policy hasn't really been effective does
that really change the motivation that
they have we're continuing the policy
and in a lot of cases the answer to that
question is no yeah so you've done a lot
of videos with learning liberty about
some of the stuff we've talked about
will link to some stuff below so people
can check that also one of the other
things you talk about a lot is police
militarization and how we've watched
that really expand I think it's directly
directly related to everything going on
with the surveillance state how much has
this expanded you know we see now when
there's riots and whatever we see things
that look like tanks on our streets we
see police officers that look like
soldiers I don't think we saw that not
too long ago you didn't so the trend of
police militarization is something that
people really talk about starting to
happen in the 1960s I think there were
some trends prior to that but didn't
really take off like it did until you
hit really Vietnam and then war on drugs
and that actually is one of the things
that we talked about in looking at and
linking up foreign policy to domestic
domestic consequences so police military
sorry yeah no so in this case like we
had the Vietnam War we then get protests
against it and then the state kind of
uses that as an excuse to become more
militarized swat teams are probably one
of the best examples SWAT teams are now
something that pretty much any
moderately sized Police Department has
so if you have a town of 50,000 or more
people
chances are you have got a SWAT team so
special weapons and tactics teams also
referred to as police paramilitary units
or PP use so the fact about the word
military American is fairly uh yeah
fairly pointed but where did those come
from we actually know exactly where they
came from
you have two people who are generally
considered responsible for SWAT teams
Daryl gates and John Nelson
so John Nelson is a what
former Marine Vietnam veteran he was
part of the elite Force Recon unit so
this unit was tasked with going deep
behind enemy lines and despite having
the name reconnaissance in the title
they were actually a very effective
killing force they engaged the enemy I
think was something 90% of the time
which was incredibly high and he came
back joined the LAPD and you have the
Watts Riots and looking at these race
riots he goes to his boss
so inspector Daryl gates who the World
War two veteran and says hey I have an
idea of how we might be able to better
control crowds and he suggests modeling
a unit after these recon units that he
had been a part of in Vietnam and so
gates likes this idea runs with it and
what was originally supposed to be
called the special weapons and attack
team but it was thought of tactically
politically unpalatable SWAT team was
born it's modeled after that particular
unit according to the LAPD history every
member of the original SWAT unit had
prior military training they were
interested in and if you read gates
biography he talks about watching what
was happening in Vietnam getting
training from the military and so you
start to see these kinds of very
intimate connections that are happening
between police and military and they're
interested in using not only those
mentalities that they've cultivated
abroad but they're also interested in
using those technologies then they've
developed how do we well if you had your
druthers but these things just not exist
at all like policing would just be
purely the way it was before all this so
policing historically in the United
States has been distinct from the
military so if you look at the
Constitution if you look at laws that
came after that probably the big one
that people point to was enacted right
after the Civil War called the Posse
Comitatus Act
and I don't even know that one that was
that one Posse Comitatus literally
translates to force of the people and so
the purpose of this law was to separate
police from the military so military
could not be used as a civilian police
force pretty much as soon as the ink is
dry this thing is getting violated it's
getting suspended in I think world war
one world war two then there are series
of court cases in the 1970s that pretty
much take any kind of sticking power
that this thing had to begin with
completely out of it and so you see this
big blurring of these lines in addition
to things like SWAT teams which comes
with in this time period the war on
drugs in the voluntary particularly
important because you see that continued
interconnectivity between domestic law
enforcement agencies and what the
federal government is doing so now you
have police departments who instead of
having their job which has historically
been to be peacekeepers right uphold
domestic law protecting the rights of
citizens both individuals who are the
perpetrators of crime and the victims of
crime instead of serving that function
they are now on quote/unquote the front
lines of to perpetual Wars the war on
drugs in the war on terror which are
different from other conflicts that
we've seen before because if you think
about Vietnam or one of the world wars
the enemy is very clearly defined and
external to the United States but with
the war on drugs you not only have
things like South American cartels that
you have people who are domestically
manufacturing selling and consuming
drugs who are enemies of this war yeah
there's been a big emphasis on homegrown
terrorism and so now your Police
Department's are tasked with another job
that is not part of their job
description and so it's been building in
a combination of all of these things I
think it's really contributed to to this
police militarization which now I think
a lot of people are more aware of yeah
which it seems like we're slowly getting
accepting of it because if you look at
you could look at you know something
like Ferguson and then you could look at
something like what's happened at
Berkeley and in both cases you see a big
sort of state response but I've talked
to people who said that the police
weren't doing anything you know like at
Berkeley that the police were just sort
of letting anti-shah runnel run across
and be violent do all this stuff and
then other people are going to have to
step in so we're in a strange place with
policing in general do I think I think
that police and I've made this argument
to people when talking about policing
and in talking about the military to
that I think a lot of times the job
that's been pushed on members of law
enforcement and members of the military
is particularly unfair one thing we
talked about in economics is ideas
comparative advantage you do what it is
that you're particularly good at
soldiers are not trained in you know to
be humanitarians like that is not their
their job description of police officers
their job description is to speak and
peacekeepers but it is a precarious
position and oftentimes people will say
thanks Jenny well but if you're the
people that they're fighting have you
know tanks and ak-47 like don't you want
them to have a superior firepower right
which my response is always yeah maybe
but if you look at what people are
actually fighting police officers with
or the probability of being shot and
killed if you're a police officer can
it's that risk assessment thing that
people aren't particularly good at right
I think police have been good put put in
a position that they weren't intended to
be in and oftentimes when we see police
are being used like SWAT teams again
provide a really good example SWAT teams
are used in a lot of times in cases
where people would look at that and say
there's really a hard case to saying
that that's appropriate like you have
SWAT teams who are being used when
people are threatening suicide for
example I have a hard time swearing in
my brain people go
out in full Kevlar in a Bearcat
so therefore bird mine resistant vehicle
for someone who's threatening to you
know shoot themselves in their house
right part of that is I think part of
the stipulations on the equipment that a
lot of police forces are getting so this
came along with that war on drugs and
war on terror people who are familiar
may be familiar with a Department of
Defense program that allows for the
transfer of excess military equipment to
law enforcement part of that include
they use it or lose it provision so if
you don't use the equipment as a police
department within a year you're supposed
to return it right part of Defense which
goes back to what we said earlier they
never want to return it but I always
want to spend more so now you literally
have the SWAT team with this all this
crazy stuff going out to stop a guy that
maybe he's jumping off the bridge right
and it creates a really strong incentive
to use these items even in cases where
they aren't appropriate pretty I guess
infamous example would be the word Keene
New Hampshire the town of about twenty
thousand people haven't had a murder in
something like two decades and yet their
Police Department got a Bearcat so a
mugging resistant vehicle yeah um it's a
little it's all over New Hampshire right
right very much everywhere and so there
are lots of cases where you see things
and this is this is not to say that you
know police having the equipment that
they need is not something that's that's
necessary yeah but I think that we
should be turning a very critical eye to
what it is that has happened in u.s.
police departments because I think it's
a it's been a growing issue for a long
time but when you start to have things
like Ferguson really put a spotlight on
it in a way that I was frankly surprised
because prior to that the thing that
people forget about is Watertown
Massachusetts so after the bombing of
the Boston Marathon you have you know
police who are removing people from
their homes to search for the suspected
bombers with no kind of pretense first
thinking that they were in a person's
house issuing curfews and things like
that and that to me was a much stronger
display of the kinds of things that I'm
talking about but Ferguson is what what
gets the play yeah so the through line
through everything we've talked about
for an hour has been just sort of that
this thing just kind of grows it kind of
grows for economic reasons and for
political reasons and everything else so
to kind of wrap this all up if if
someone's watching this and goes why I
don't like that I don't like this idea
that this thing's growing all the time
and taking more money and not doing
things that are economically sound or
socially sound and I don't want more
militarized police on the streets and
all that what would you say are some of
the ways that we can start influencing
our politicians and other people to real
some of this stuff back in I think that
one thing that people can do is to
really educate themselves about things
like the terror threat so knowing that
you're more likely to be killed by a gun
wielding toddler yeah then you are
killing my parents freak out every time
I see you tog area dangerous um knowing
that being aware that what is happening
today cannon does have a very real
impact on what may happen tomorrow and
that's not intended to be alarmist or a
very you know tinfoil hat like young me
super careful because they're going to
try to use this for something right um
but to look at and be aware of these
types of issues to understand how it is
that we've gotten to this point because
there is one thing and that we say this
toward I think is look at the conclusion
of our book is just because we see these
things doesn't necessarily mean that
it's a permanent state of affairs and
one thing that can be a very effective
control on inappropriate expansions in
the scale and scope of government is the
ideology of the citizenry and so there
have been cases historically where you
look and people just they're not
to swallow certain things yeah when
people when they're elected officials
attempt them and so if people make their
voice heard if they develop and they
articulate those preferences that this
is not something that is acceptable I
think that there's a real power there so
be smart be engaged be aware I think
those are all the things I've been I've
been trying to do around here I've
thoroughly enjoyed this and for more on
Abby and her work you can check out
Abigail our Hall
[Music]
you